are there any skills in chess that are
transferable to poker
so as you're playing around with poker a
little bit now
how fundamentally different of a game is
it
what i find the most transferable
probably is not like letting
past decisions
dictate
future thinking yeah
but in terms of the patterns in the
betting strategies and all that kind of
stuff uh what about bluffing
do you because i've left way too much
it does seem you enjoy bluffing and uh
daniel negron was saying yeah you're
quite good at it
uh but yeah it has very little material
to go by sample size is small yeah
no i mean i enjoy bluffing for um the
more the gambling aspects the thrill of
so not the technical aspect of the
bluffing like you would on the
chessboard
not bluffing in the same sense but there
is some element um
but i do enjoy it on on the chessboard
like if i um know that like oh i
successfully scared away my opponent for
making the best move that's of course
satisfying
in that same way it might be satisfying
in poker right that you represent
something you scare away your opponent
yeah the same kind of like yeah and also
like you tell a story
you try and tell a story and then
they believe it
yeah
tell a story with your betting with your
um
all the different other cues yeah do you
like the money aspect the the betting
strategies
so it's like it's like it's almost like
another layer on top of it right like
it's it's the uncertainty
in the cards
but the betting there's so much freedom
to the betting
i'm not very good at that so
i cannot say that i understand it
completely
you know
when it comes to
different sizing and
well and i just haven't studied it
enough how much of luck is part of poker
would you say from what what you've seen
versus skill
i mean it's so different in the sense
that you can be
one of the best players in the world and
lose two or three years in a row without
that being
being like a massive outlier
okay the the the thing that more than
one person told me
that you're very good at is trash
talking
i don't think i am
a lot of people who
make
those observations about me i think they
just expect very very little so they
expect
from the best chess player in the world
that just anything that's non-robotic
is interesting
also when it comes to trash talking like
i have the biggest advantage in the
world that i'm the best of what i'm
doing so trash talking becomes very very
very easy because i can back it up yeah
yeah but a lot of people that are
extremely good at stuff don't trash talk
and they're not good at it i don't think
i'm very good at it it's just that i can
back it up which makes it seem that i'm
i'm better and also you're even doing it
now
also being non-robotic or not completely
robotic yeah
yeah i'm you're not trash talking you're
just stating facts that's right
have you ever have you ever considered
that uh
there will be trash talking and over the
chess board and some of the big
tournaments
like adding that kind of component or
even talking you know
um that would that completely distract
from the gamer chess no i think it could
be um funny
when people play off fan games when they
play blitz games like people trash talk
all the time it's a normal part of the
game
you